hi and welcome back to the Simon
Oxford's book club I'm Simon Oxford
this is the book we don't actually have
a physical clutter prefix that you are
the club this is the book club where
anybody who wants to join long reads the
same book as me for the past little
while it's actually been longer than I
said it work because I've been really
busy with the PhD sorry it has been spqr
by Mary beard this is a book basically
detailing about seven hundred years of
history between the founding of Rome and
the point in to12 ad where the Emperor
Caracalla gave citizenship to all
inhabitants the Roman Empire which kind
of is like a key milestone event and the
short review I'm going to give you the
start this video is it's absolutely
amazing before moving on to the main
body of the video though there are two
announcements very quickly first of all
that is a Goodreads group for this book
club now so I have Goodreads and there's
a link down there in the description
I'm Simon ox fist on great reason
Goodreads and you can add me but there's
also now a scientist of his book club
group which anybody can join and join in
the discussion so hopefully well at the
moment there's sort of threads on there
about the thing which you're reading at
the time so that was SPQR and also
another book which I have found there
which I'm also doing a book club on very
soon as like a special like so so
there's discussion threads about that
that we poles buy that kind of thing and
I kind of want you guys to use it to get
to know each other and to get to know so
I can get to know you because you know
we're all massive nerds but like books
we've got something in common so let's
kind of you know safety in numbers let's
mesh together into the community so
that's a resource which is up and
running it's got about like 90 people in
at the moment so let's get that growing
second announcement is because of a poll
that we did on the Goodreads group we're
going to be reading --next sapiens a
brief history of humankind by you Val
Noah Harare I think I got his name right
which is another big history kind of
book so over the next four weeks I'm
going to try and get this one like speed
this one out much quicker compared to
this one because I am gonna be good and
give you dedicated
that's what we're gonna be reading so if
you'd like to read that along with me
I'd recommend that you either get a copy
from your local library support local
bookshop and we go on that experience
together after that I'm just gonna pick
a fiction book because I want us to do
something that's non
that's not a nonfiction and we can have
a bit more of an in-depth discussion
about the themes and that kind of thing
so next sapiens a brief history of
humankind so I've already told you that
this book is absolutely fantastic now
why did I think that and who do I think
should read it so as already mentioned
this is quite a big chunk of history of
this book is looking at it's looking it
from about 500 BC to approximately 200
AD or C II and it's detailing a part of
history that at least in the UK
everybody has been taught at school
everybody does the Romans I think in
primary school and in secondary school
and this is actually a point I want to
come back to later but we focus in
school very much on the military of Rome
I think it'd be fair to say because we
were a province that was conquered
perhaps it makes sense that you know you
say to kids these were the the Italians
that ruled over us 2,000 years ago look
at what they did they made shields like
tortoises out of their shields isn't
that cool and it very much focuses on
one really quite small aspect of what
Roman life was like this book is very
much about the bigger themes and it's a
bit much greater slice across Roman
society you know includes everything
from the the political system through
women's representation in Rome how Rome
was perceived by others how Rome
perceived itself there's it's just it's
so much more interesting than how we
would talk the Romans in school I mean
history in English are my strongest
subjects at school like maths definitely
wasn't science wasn't I think if I'd
honesty if I read this book when I was
sort of 1516 I probably and ended up
doing a history or classics degree
because this is the the best the best
way to convince somebody that history
isn't boring history is relevant and
that there's so much you can learn from
what's happened in the past and interest
in the Mary beard
talks about at the very end of the book
about the fact that you know it's not to
say that we're gonna learn anything
directly useful from how the Romans did
this system of government it's not that
knowledge itself isn't gonna you know
help us or even looking at where it went
wrong is that's not going to help us
it's the techniques and did an analysis
which you developed from looking at it
not the actual facts but the mechanisms
that you used to investigate the facts
marry bid incidentally is a fantastic
fantastic author her prose is like a
razor blade it's so crisp it's really
sharp there's no ambiguity whatsoever
about what she means it's consistently
engaging I mean honestly this is now the
gold standard for me of how you should
write a popular history book because
this was just I mean every time I came
to it and you come away with something
some incredibly well articulated point
that the point itself is interesting but
you're also kind of marveling at how
succinctly and how well she argued it
right there that's BAE and in a way the
kind of marvel at the way in which she
analyzes stuff there are interesting
gobbets that you learn about the Romans
from this book for example the the fact
that in some area I was it was one
province in order to be elected an
official I think I'm added mayor of a
town you have to be a certain level of
wealth and that was a common thing you
know through it throughout Roman society
but in that particular town they denoted
wealth by the number of tiles on your
roof which to us sounds really weird but
they were she so talks to the logic
about why that would be the case another
really interesting a bit of analysis
just to give you an example of a sort of
the thought process that basically
occurs throughout this book she looks at
a mural in the city of Pompeii which was
behind a bar and talks about the bars
position in in social life not
necessarily that particular one but the
idea of a bar in Roman society what it
meant where you were socially
economically if you were frequenting
about what what kind of person was going
there and there's a mural which had
different Greek philosophers I think it
was it was it was some number who came
up in seven who'd all done particularly
famous things and they all had their
mottos related to their work defaced and
all talking about defecation and about
taking poems and she sort of says well
yeah this is obviously it tells you
several things that tells you the fact
that there's a clear class divide the
fact that the poor perceive the rich is
having this this whole culture this was
Greek stuff which you know it much is
sort of we do now I suppose you know how
people
the Opera and then you have people that
watch x-factor there's like there's a
better perceived Reba culture device but
it also says that yes say yes yes
there's a divide sort of into social
strata but it's saying that they're
mocking them but in order to mark them
they have to have a certain level of
understanding of the thing itself so
it's not funny to defile some Greek
philosophers saying about with poo
unless you know kind of what that
philosopher was famous for so actually
infer something about the level of
education of the lowest the lowest
social strata in Roman society and is
that kind of analysis that I just was
just brilliant throughout this book
absolutely amazing I honestly can't
recommend a thought processes behind
this enough and it looks like I said at
the start right so in history in the UK
at least we focus on sort of the sexy
parts of Roman history in the military
and you know you color in in primary
school or the Roman legionary all that
kind of stuff but this to me is so much
more interesting this looks at the much
much bigger questions in history like
asking why we so obsessed with the idea
of the personality of these Emperor's
how you know how important really was it
that perhaps Claudius was a little bit
mad he even was evil was that political
smear does that taste only about the
political system and the manner of
succession and the Augustinian model you
know how important were the
personalities how important were by
contrast as the trade factors the way in
which Rome interacted with its its
neighbors another thing that occurs
quite early on is looking at the
mythology of Rome at about the founding
of Roman people saying well of course
Roman emperors were going to be
particularly treacherous and you know
and murder people to assassinate little
officers to get where they want because
it's you know it's in their nature
Romulus did it to Remus well actually
perhaps the mythology was retconned or
changed to fit to the activities of
rooms at the time so because people went
around murdering lots of people to get
political office perhaps they modified
the mythology to reflect the societies
it's it's it's the other way around that
we tend can kind of tend to be thought I
tend to be taught this stuff the other
thing the Olympic takeaway I think I go
from this book was maybe I'm a layman
thinking this but I don't think I am I
always used to think that the Empire the
Roman Empire
I thought basically after the death of
Julius Caesar and when his adopted son
Augustus became an emperor became the
first emperor I was thought that that
Empire was much more interesting than
the Republic before it possibly because
I've been taught about the Romans via
them solve the militaristic route and
you know this book told me that I was
totally wrong the foundation of the
Republic is so much more interesting
than the empire the political
maneuverings the ideas that went into
the Republic and sort of analyzing well
for one thing why was there a Roman
Republic when it was no reason really no
different in 500 BC from well any number
of city-states why were the Romans so
singularly obsessed with their military
successes because it was a military
organization well there was a larger
military organization within the Roman
Republic the Roman Republic was very
focused on warfare and she makes a very
compelling case that when we look at the
Republic transitioning into the empire
that wasn't the consequence of big men
in history like Caesar being
assassinated or Augustus forming an
empire and all the really interesting
stuff that happened then it was an
inevitable consequence of the way that
the Roman Republic was constructive the
way that the society was so based on
military might and also individual power
so it neva tably was gonna result in an
autocratic military regime regime so
yeah so III really I was blown away by
how good this was if you look on the
back cover of this and on the inside on
both ends marry bid is being showered
with praise for this book and honestly
totally agree with all anybody who's
interested in history should be this
book anybody possibly who likes thinking
about those bigger points you know
whether the big men in history or the
people who you know got things done or
was it the broader factors looking more
analytically at for example the role of
women and there is there's a thread of
sort of looking looking at the how well
represented on the scene remember women
were the Scioscia the social factors the
economic factors you know you're looking
at what was it like for the 99% of
Romans that we have very little evidence
for
anybody who's interesting those kind of
big sweeping questions or is interested
in the room and specifically definitely
read it equally if you're thinking maybe
if you're going about if you're going to
go to uni or think you'd in humanities
subject read this for the love of Qadri
Pitts I'm struggling to think of anybody
who shouldn't read this the only thing I
could say is it is quite a meaty book
it's 500 pages detect your while to read
and it is pretty dense so you know don't
don't read it if you like some want
something frothy uh-hum but you know if
it's a great train and plain book you
lose yourself in it you know a hundred
pages at a time yeah I think you know
what I think about this pineapple so
that was what I thought a best week you
are fantastic by comparison
I have read this recently and I'm gonna
be doing a special book club talking
with a bunch of friends of mine doing a
group discussion about Harry Potter in
the cursed child so if you haven't read
it I'd recommend that you try and read
it honestly it takes like six hours it's
not long I think that'll be uploaded
within a the next couple of days to this
channel yeah looking forward to having a
bit of group discussion on this one and
then next as I say is sapiens a brief
history of human Cup it's the cellar
alarm so this isn't the sponsored video
I want to be very clear and I will be
very clear in future when videos are
sponsored but this video is but
supported I suppose is the best way to
put it by a company called blink kissed
I respect you guys way too much to just
peddle stuff at you and I've been
contacted by so many people like trying
to get me to plug stuff in videos or you
know do reviews or whatnot I actually
reply to this one because it's an
amazing service
so basically blink kissed is a company
that has condensed forms of books like
I'm talking you read a book in ten
minutes or you listen to a book in ten
minutes and that's mostly what I'm doing
actually been listening to I think over
the past couple of weeks I've listened
to about 20 books and they take like ten
minutes each I can do them when I'm
walking to work or if I'm on a train or
something
so blinkers is something that you either
get on your phone or you can get it
online and you have different other
subscriptions so the cup
gave me a bunch of months for free which
I've been making the most of and they've
given me a special link so there's a
link on screen and down in the
description if you click that link and
you choose if you like what you see
which I actually pretty think you will I
choose this to partner with because I
genuinely think it's really really good
and I think you'll like it if you slip
that link then I get a certain cut of if
you buy a subscription for example so it
helps yourself by getting a really
really great service but it also helps
me and kind of helps keep the phd
lifestyle going because living
hand-to-mouth
a little bit here guys but like i say
it's really really good and like just to
go through some of the stuff that i've
been reading recently what listening to
wondrous I definitely recommend seven
Habits of Highly Effective People a book
that my supervisor actually gave me at
the start my PhD so comparing how how
much information I retained from the
book and from the audio like they've put
the condensed version just as much on it
like genuinely I also listen to a really
interesting one on Tesla by Margaret
Cheney of really interesting one on
Teddy Roosevelt oxygen how to win
friends and influence people by Dale
Carnegie like an absolute classic - ten
minutes listen - I now save myself
reading a really long book which is
probably gonna have exactly the same out
information just with lots of padding in
so if you like the sound of reading
dozens of books I'm actually gonna try
and set myself a challenge maybe to
relight 50 books in a week with the
service if you like the sound of that
and you want to support me click that
link get yourself a blink case even if
it's just for a month see what it's like
I really really think you're gonna like
it
thanks very much - bling kiss for
reaching out and offering this deal -
you know you guys thank you for watching
and I'll be seeing you in a couple of
weeks to talk about sapiens